listen this is partisan fontaine party
if you match the top of the-- - pastor -
poverty power range of the section a sex
symbol to launch at orgasm and these are
my essentials Xbox NBA 2k number one
essential for party Fontaine is a
must-have absolutely what's that my vote
- it is it's 2k that's what I put in the
majority of my work
they don't go by where I'll play the
game playing the game 24/7 if I got to
go somewhere and I know I'm gonna be
there for more than two three days my
xbox coming with me
this is one of the series Jones they
gotta make me an orange one for this
just run-of-the-mill
Best Buy I think this is actually a
cheap headphone so I'll just you know
I'm saying missus this is just plug up
and godo so I don't got too much extra
moving pieces plug it up new unmute
that's it it's reliable you know I'm
saying reliable when they first came to
market I was a police station household
until Xbox came out and we had to go get
one me and my brother who was like
listen we don't want nothing else for
Christmas both sides just making sure
y'all get these Xbox and make sure is it
I'm sure he's probably alive or on NBA
streets one of those you know I'm saying
with a halo halo was big on the first
Xbox - yeah if they put an Xbox inside
the police station that's the only
possible way I'm going back to
PlayStation
this is african shea butter you know I'm
saying
smells good it look weird when it's
broke up like this but it actually works
wonders you know I'm saying is like a
miracle lubricant moisturizer right here
you know I'm saying especially for me
you know black people we got like these
parts of our hands like right here right
here we're normally stay actually no
matter what so this is like a mustard
really get that out of there you know
I'm saying you feel me you just get a
piece like this like so there's on your
hand everything real good like my hand
gonna be oily for the rest of the day
now it's voiceover so you know I'm
saying dad feels like that saying you're
never gonna be ashy for like a week you
good now you only gotta do nothing no so
we straight
shiny shea butter as a whole it's
definitely an essential you don't say I
keep you looking young too because it
preserve my sexy everybody should have
this in every home if you ever been a
she when you take a shower this $3 tub
will last you a whole year 365 it just
did so much for my life and the women
out there I mean I had to dedicate a
song to his college shea butter you
actually listen to it right now as a
matter of fact so on iTunes Spotify
every other platform that has music shea
butter party finds him holder I'm saying
hold all my cards a lot of good scammers
in the world so I'm not gonna show you
how my cards you know yeah I pick up on
the numbers quick my ID it took me a
long time to get this more my Amex you
feel me got no limit on his money honey
spend all day
I always keep this with me dog always
keep my my benefit card you feel me for
my Food Stamp days so right before I go
to buy some [ __ ] always just remember I
like you could be back here tomorrow you
feel me but my other essential is my
card or my money clip
I really don't carry cash that much you
know I'm saying so it's just extra bulky
in your pocket for no reason so when
anything could be held in a little clip
and I think it's type of old school too
so you know I'm saying you pull out the
money to white these white keys are
definitely in my central list you know
I'm saying I probably got like four or
five bunch of white t-shirts in my
career right now you can never wear the
same white t-shirt out twice like you
see this t-shirt right here highs on
this I can never wear this shirt again
out after that it becomes a gym shirt I
don't care what city I go to ok well
land that I'm going to the nearest
Marshalls and I'm getting packs or white
t-shirt socks and underwear this is just
amazing
all around white t-shirts almost and I
get them in a medium too so you could
really see me out here I probably got
too many open to be honest but [ __ ] out
the package going to body you don't even
got a higher in it a little wrinkles
fall off there's some love white
t-shirts like this Alf on you one this
is pretty good rich like the polar ones
for some reason he always will do I like
this one Nordstrom's got a good brand a
white t-shirt the way to just fit you
feel me like almost close the fit is
everything yo I haven't won a black
t-shirt in years you know saying
somebody suggested I switch it up one
time but for right now it's the white
team
[Music]
the cognac just to get your party
started
absolutely must go to if I'm in the club
they know I'm asking for one of these
two of these
this is self-explanatory it's been just
been making babies and refreshing the
population for years when you drink a
certain amount of Hennessy right you
know I'm saying Hennessy to start
rocking with you back they send you a
very special birthday want you from this
as partisan in the front just for me and
all the amount of Hennessy I've been
able to consume over the past 37 years
cheers to them and this was the first
year so they better they better keep it
going
I think I was like 14 5 14 I went to a
club and my brother gave me two things
right he had a first thing game he was a
Long Island iced tea why he would give
me that I have no idea I hated it
so he switched it out for honey and I
was like I just won any bad now I drink
it straight you know I'm saying I just
don't like the extra calories when you
put juice and whatnot in its largest
industry even when I'm in a club I give
it a little swirl I'm never going
nowhere I've been in the nobody house
I'm going to no restaurant
I'm never going anywhere and aged some
food and not had to put salt on me I
hate when I go to restaurants and they
don't got the salt and pepper shaker on
the table like yeah I really think y'all
cooks is this good that I'm not gonna
have to do nothing to it like I just
took it off the table completely
something I asked for they'd be mad they
bring it out in like a little bowl of
salt soy has to go on everything I don't
care what it is if I mean I gotta have
salt on it they tell me it's not good
for me but I go to the doctor to check
my blood pressure me blazing good enough
man I don't put salt on the cheeseburger
before I don't you fill me I don't upper
so on everything
I don't even discriminate against salt
all of them sea salt
the pink saw all of that and filming
adobo is available any season it's all
of that you know I'm saying
I ready for this these are very special
and very essential I don't make too many
like big purchases you know I'm saying
where I go to too too far out for one
item and I'm saying but these I like
kind of had to track down I want to be
bad and I really wanted the green pared
but they told me it was like an
exclusive only released in Chicago or so
I've been trying to track them down but
I'm gonna get them to Virgil edition
annoyed Vuitton shades essential buy you
no matter what you got on Rockaway just
the white tee come outside with these
like oh yeah he fly today you feel me
so this is definitely a must the thing
is a dark is a [ __ ] though like
you know you can't really wear him at
night people do but I need to see I'm
already blind so you feel me like I just
became a whole different person just now
like you see it - I see it I see me
looking good
roughly not honey glasses sunglasses and
shades and frames those are the
essential part you know I'm saying you
got to have a good pair of frames long
night you don't want nobody to know I
got a little collection going I got an
extensive plethora of cartier frames
vintage you know I'm saying that I keep
a nose the important to me but these
Louise is like these like the newest
hottest thing on the market and I'm
gonna keep them forever so when my kids
get older but oh they be able to pull
them out you feel me
I might get arrested interview like this
you always got to smell good Gucci
Guilty you can't go wrong no chance walk
past a woman who got you know i'm sandi
say smell her scent is like the most odd
thing to memory so if you smell good day
never gonna forget you like first time I
got it it was a gift for my birthday as
a matter of fact I work I know it's a
trap ladies you try and get your man
some smell good you want you and your
men to smell like party Fontaine he
can't be party Fontaine by at least you
could try to smell like I got older
brother so he always had this you know
I'm saying I used to sneak in his room
and still
I go to school because I always know as
much from him the smelling good was
always a thing of mine always had to I'm
somebody that's always on the phone I
feel like everybody always anything so
me especially I gotta keep it portable
it's gonna die and being outside with a
dead phone is like being on nobody you
can't do nothing
you can't call nobody you can't post
nothing you just out you just outside go
home like I'm ready to go home if I'm
out and my phone died I'm ready to go so
I got to keep one of these this one's
pretty far actually so I don't matter
where you go you can just plug your
train up and charge it together charge
the phone got the iphone wire right here
for whatever reason if you got an
Android or what we don't got nothing
else to talk about
why is my text messages good Wow what
I'm like that though my portable charger
essential everyday listen if I say my
phone died I probably lied because I got
this on me you feel me I'm probably
definitely lying you know you know I'm
saying but I've got to keep this
portable charger everywhere
[Music]
do rag this is just a must I mean I feel
like since the beginning of the time
black men have hat hair and when to take
care of it you feel me and this is just
this is all I'll go to method do it you
feel me don't care if you got braids or
waves even back when I had two waves i
status and then i'll put a stocking cap
in the top of the waves you know in the
top of this dimensional waves was extra
crispy so right now just keep my braids
fresh keep everything you know I'm
saying this also be an accessory door
nowadays you can go outside with just
tucking the tail I'm an old school
player I took him to tell still no they
are absolutely not this one right here
that's what we call it silky you know
I'm saying you see that nice luster it
has to it right there you see it on
camera
it's just silky right here this is to be
taken serious you see a man all in this
way I have Edison this man really cares
about his hair and how he looks you
found me if I see somebody outside and
2019 with a colored direct like any
other color visage black oh he just got
to be solid it got to be a solid color
bro it can't have no designs dude I
gotta be solid bro
maybe an old 304 already had the two
tones or something like that but now I
gotta be solid for me listen closest the
silk pillowcase black girls love me
I got silk pillowcases this also go hand
in hand with the shea butter listen
especially women you know I'm saying
they got natural hair they had done they
can't lay their head on no cotton you
feel me it's gonna mess up their hair
give it frizzy
like me to let our braids this is why
I'm allowed to not wear my do rock every
night I got soaked pillowcases keep
everything the way it's supposed to be
and this one happens to be
because it's me on just like my thing
you know how a regular pillow case would
be all hot side of your face all sweaty
not this right keep you cool they go
boom so back when I was really like
grinding you know I'm saying making
music I wasn't getting my hair done all
that often so I just was wearing hats
all the time no one had that I had was
orange you know I'm saying is I just
what is same orange at all the time all
the time people started like oh we're
going chat you feel me like one of my
homies hear me like a fake album cover
for me and it was just the orange hat
man his orange had been through a lot so
now I was like I can't abandon it now
that I'm here and now I got different
ones I got my logo on this one the
section they'd been so me and beans has
been through a lot we've been through
everything and now one is just my color
so when you see orange you guys think
party fontaine just right you know much
black I don't got for this damn dude
it's my deodorant
this is what I use you know I'm saying
don't let them fool you this not women's
deodorant this is unisex deodorant you
feel me I can't use no gel deodorants to
make me feel like a creep well anybody
could like put on gel deodorant with a
straight face is a serial killer there's
a solid two swipes you're good all day
maybe even two days forever you know
trying to keep it to one day
smells like shower fresh look at that
secret is the secret weapon yo men
deodorant smelled too strong they smell
like a whole cologne like bro I don't
need my deodorant they smell like
Cologne I just need to be deodorant so
this is that ain't gonna clash with you
they don't give you those nasty ass like
bumps or like boy you know I'm saying
you're out of God's secret
Hey look this is party fontaine thank
you guys for checking out my essentials
make sure you go stream and download my
project underrated available everywhere
[Music]